welcome back to New rockstars I'm Eric
Voss and Guardians of the Galaxy vol 3
finally answers some big questions about
Rocket Raccoon which I finally feel
comfortable calling him without the
threat of him clawing my face off
spoiler won't even worry continue
seriously you're not gonna get or enjoy
this video if you don't watch the movie
first in Guardians of the Galaxy vol 3
rocket was confirmed to be a North
American raccoon from Earth but with a
unique brain that confounds even the
high evolutionary so what is the real
story behind Rocket's unique condition
the reason behind his big brain and what
was the deeper meaning behind that
mysterious Moment In Limbo with Lila the
answer to this question may be the big
answer to everything in the Marvel
Universe but a few quick announcements
after the successful expansion of our
new deep dive Channel our live stream
break room can now be found on its own
channel in the new rockstars Network
called the break room I'm so excited for
this it's the future home of all break
room episodes and new Rockstar's after
shows so subscribe for a few fun videos
this month in an official launch in June
three channels in the new rockstars
Network I can't believe it and you can
support this growing Network by grabbing
some Guardians inspired shirts at nerd
riot.shop like this 89p13 shirt from the
deep dive collection okay so Guardians
volume 3 confirms that rocket subject 89
p13 was part of batch 89 of the high
evolutionary Herbert windham's
experiments which also included the
Lotter Lyla The Walrus thiefs and the
albino White Rabbit floor Rocket's first
real friends who unfortunately don't
make it now the Final Act of this film
where I could revisits this cage to free
the remaining kits and reads a label
form on the inside of the door lumbus
Wildlife Center maybe Columbus but it
looks like it's just lumbus
ter321-190021 origin North America
kingdom Animalia phylum chordata genus
procyon species procyon LaTour common
name raccoon procyon LaTour is the genus
and species name of raccoons and we
actually heard this in the Guardians
Inferno song for volume 2 written by
James Gunn and Tyler Bates and performed
by David Hasselhoff getting down and
dirty
so this form judging for the fact that
it looks old it looks like it's the same
kind of cage that rocket was in before
would suggest to a set rocket came from
her from North America Herbert Windham
earlier told Peter Quill that he had
visited Earth in the past you must find
counter Earth familiar counter Earth I
visited your planet many years ago Earth
hasn't been my planet in a long time
Windham created counter Earth in the
image of the earth that he had last
visited so presumably this was in the
1980s which might be when he got all
those raccoons that included the one
that became rocket now the average
lifespan of a raccoon in the wild is
five years but with abundant food and
shelter they can live past a decade up
to 20 years rocket was given various
cybernetic enhancements that likely
expanded his lifespan to something
closer to that of a human remember his
booking screen in the first film listed
a genetically augmented cerebral cortex
genetically meaning its DNA was coded
that way before his birth from an
embryonic stage genetic doesn't mean all
the cybernetic implants at Wyndham and
His science Escape rocket when he was a
kid so if rocket was a kit taken from a
wildlife center in North America when
did that genetic experimentation take
place what divine intervention
intervened with this thing from before
its birth the moment of conception well
this gets at the key detail about rocket
in this film the fact that unlike all of
windham's other experiments only rocket
has a brain capable of true invention
Windham showed rocket as Evolution
chamber which by the way I believe is at
least inspired by the terrigen midst of
Marvel Comics which creates Inhumans but
I don't think this is exactly that when
that Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtle want to
be turned violent due to these test
subjects producing beta microsamino
protein only rocket is able to determine
why it's caused by a faulty filter in
that mist chamber and this completely
unnerves Windham into thinking he missed
something about Rocket's brain Windham
later tells his recorder that his
genetically perfect children are only
capable of rote memorization but in
hundreds of years of my Creations only
one has known true invention it goes on
to say a populist unable to think what
hasn't yet been thought will die on the
vine basically Herbert window is sane
the ability to think critically to solve
problems to create is the one darwinian
trait that allows societies to evolve
James Gunn's basically calling out all
creators out there stop just doing
what's already been done create
something new it also poses a sad future
for all the kids in cages on Windham
ship they really need Papa Jacks to look
after them because these kids are dumb I
mean Herbert Williams words not mine
anyway that organ Corp welcome video so
that Wyndham has been at this for over
300 years so why did he fail in all the
other instances than rocket at inspiring
this true creativity the closest thing
this film gives us to an answer was
hinted at by Lila's ghostly form when
rocket was in this limbo realm nearly
dead Lila says rocket has to stay in the
living realm saying you still have a
purpose here Rocket says a purpose for
what they made us for nothing stupid
experiments to be thrown away Delilah
corrects them saying the most important
line of this movie there are the hands
that make us and then there are the
hands that guide the hands my beloved
raccoon the story has been yours all
along you just didn't know it geology is
a 19 time award-winning skin hair and
body care company recognized in men's
health Oprah daily hypebeast birdie
Esquire in GQ their products are built
around just a handful of powerful proven
ingredients that have been dressed
tested by dermatologists for decades
just take a quick 30 second diagnostic
quiz geology will create a simple and
effective skin care or hair care routine
customized just for you geologists
co-wash and their deodorant are just so
great and I use them all the time right
now they're offering a special offer for
a skincare sampler pack and geology
skincare stuff is in a league of its own
geology's line of skincare products can
help you fight acne reduce oil-ness
prevent wrinkles combat dark or puffy
under eyes have smoother hydrated skin
and Target signs of aging there's never
been a better time to try geology than
right now for a limited time use code
rockstars100 to get 100 off your
personalized 30 days skincare sampler
set all you have to cover is the 495 for
shipping what a deal on top of that new
Rockstar's fans get an exclusive bonus
offer of up to 50 off on an additional
skin hair and body product of your
choice when you add it to your trial
click the link in the description or go
to
g-e-o-l-o-g dot i e slash rockstars100
to get started it took me three viewings
to figure out what Lila meant by the
hands that guide the hands because my
mind kept going to that hot hot pottery
scene and ghost Peter does reference
Swayze in this movie and Lila is
essentially Rockets Swayze from Ghost in
the scene this being bracket story all
along gets to what James gun's been
saying about this movie but according to
the Galaxy Trilogy has been the story of
the secret protagonist's rocket and the
hands that guide the hands referred to a
higher power a cosmic force in the MCU
mythology that blessed rocket from the
moment of his conception with a unique
genetic condition one that he exhibited
at Birth that made him uniquely
intelligent uniquely Brave and uniquely
capable of problem solving more than any
other one of windham's experiments
Wyndham For Better or Worse mostly worse
built on those genetic blessings to
complete rocket with a reshaped skull a
new backbone to make him bipedal and
opposable thumb so he could do math
equations on a Blackboard and of course
engineer all these wonderful things so
that rocket could reach his full
potential but Windham didn't do all of
it there was a higher power before
Windham ever got there a Creator whose
selected rocket for this greater purpose
it was that condition that caused rocket
to step forward as a kit in that cage
when Windham reached out his hand while
all the other kids cowered to the back
of the cage something made rocket Brave
in that moment before Windham ever
touched him rocket was forged to be a
hero we can actually compare rocket in
the high evolutionary to Peter Quill and
ego ego had created countless Offspring
but only one of them Peter Quill with a
special genetic condition inherited from
Meredith quill and her father Jason made
Peter sturdy enough to carry ego
Celestial Gene and for Rocket it was
these hens that guide the hands that
made his brain special enough so that
after Windham operated on him he could
become the mcu's cleverest and quickest
engineer so who are the hands that guide
the hands the Mind goes to the metaphor
of a puppeteer and the MCU has given us
a lot of those lately celestials who
create planets and beings who live on
them in this Cosmic reproduction cycle
Kang who manipulates timelines in the
Multiverse Kevin Who crafts and edits
storylines according to a corporate
algorithm the selfish gods of omnipotent
City who spend all their time in orgies
and then there's eternity a cosmic
entity Beyond this realm of existence
who may or may not have turned into
Chris Hemsworth's daughter if we want to
attribute this special genetic condition
to a mute rotation then this one force
that links Merida quill to the hands
that guide the hands of Rocket's origin
could be the Phoenix force one of the
oldest known Cosmic entities in Marvel
lore considered the guardian of creation
and the Genesis of mutant kind perhaps
an aberration to the celestial's plan of
biodiversity but based on everything
James Gunn has done with these movies I
think from his perspective this higher
power is a force of good I don't think
he's going to want to say that Kang is
the author of all of our pain I don't
think the answer is Mephisto like in
most other cases yes but not in this one
no Mephisto would be the cosmic source
of all of our grief and there must be an
opposing Force to that in Christian
theology that would just be what God is
but I think the MCU is going to give it
a more abstract form and I think we're
talking about a force that will just be
defined as either mistress love or
simply love or the one above all there's
also the entity of Gaia an elder god
that I believe has been pitched to James
Gunn in the past but he has shot down
that theory perhaps someone who has
pre-selected a specific lineup of
Champions that include rocket For an
upcoming Secret Wars conflict to save
the Multiverse we'll see but the hands
that guide the hands sounds exactly what
Peter went this when he saw his mother
as he held an infinity stone it sounds
like Thanos seen young Gamora in the
Soul Stone and it sounds like when shuri
finally saw ramonda in the ancestral
plane while finding Neymar I think it's
the same heart power that yondu and
kraglan have to access to command the
yaka Arrow it's any time any of these
characters lives have intersected with
the force of love in a tangible form
maybe it's that hand realm that Dr
Strange briefly passed through in the
2016 Doctor Strange film whatever these
hands that guide to hands are I believe
there is a reason they punish the high
evolutionary for playing God in this
movie with what the literal skull of a
dead God and I honestly think for now
there's nothing wrong with calling this
abstract Force the hands that guide the
hands really because I never want
Unchained Melody out of my head reminder
to subscribe to our new channel to Deep
dive and our new channel the break room
and you can support us by grabbing some
Merchant nerd riot.shop you can follow
me on Instagram and Twitter at avos
following the rockstars And subscribe to
new rockstars for more analysis
everything you love thanks for watching
bye
[Music]
thank you